et dans ce contexte déjà tendu la
décision d'un élu ump de l'essonne sème
à nouveau le trouble
le maire de draveil veut suspendre
toutes les aides sociales municipales
aux familles des fauteurs de troubles
à plusieurs reprises déjà des députés
avaient envisagé la suppression des
allocations
alors ces mesures sont-elles légales et
applicables réponse avec laeticia
legendre et jean francois monier draveil
une commune populaire représentatifs de
la banlieue parisienne
c'est ici hier que son député maire ump
a décidé de suspendre immédiatement les
aides financières de la ville aux
familles des fauteurs de troubles
cantine aides au logement aux vacances
ils souhaitent par ses suspensions des
municipales que les parents prennent
leur responsabilité c'est celle ci qui
sont des administrés pâle parfaitement
discrétionnaire qui seront visés il ne
s'agit pas des ânes nationale même si en
tant que député je m'empresse de vous le
dire je crois que la réflexion à partir
de l'exemple des aides locales doit être
extrapolée aux aides nationales
mais rien ne dit que le tribunal
administratif validera ces sanctions du
maire de draveil
au niveau national depuis une loi de
janvier 2004 il n'est plus possible de
suspendre ou de supprimer les
prestations familiales en cas
d'absentéisme scolaire
le système a été jugé par un groupe
d'experts en 2003 comme étant
inefficaces et contraires au droit
européen
inefficace parce qu'en fait il n'y avait
que neuf mille signalement par an ce qui
était loin de traduire la réalité
d'absentéisme
pourtant à l'assemblée il ya une semaine
nicolas sarkozy évoquait la possibilité
de revenir sur cette loi
quand on n'exerce pas son autorité
doit-on bénéficier de toutes les
allocations
aujourd'hui les magistrats répondent il
existe d'autres dispositifs pour
responsabiliser les parents notamment
des amendes
on dispose d'un arsenal juridique
l'article 227-17 du code pénal notamment
qui prévoit deux ans d'emprisonnement
qui prévoit 75000 euros d'amendé à
l'encontre des parents qu'ils
n'exerçaient pas l'autorité parentale
alors je crois qu'on est en train de se
payer de mots à l'heure actuelle
pour les associations familiales
supprimer ses allocations toucher au
portefeuille des parents c'est rendre
encore plus vulnérables des familles
déjà fragile et